let's talk about what's happened in
haiti
in the middle of the night on wednesday
president jovenel moise was assassinated
he was shot and killed in his home by
men armed with high caliber weapons
dragging the caribbean nation deeper
into crisis
and political instability this political
vacuum
is extremely dangerous we know from
haiti's past when things like this
happen
violence tends to come very quickly
moise's wife martine was also shot and
is said to be in a critical condition
in response to the attack the dominican
republic shut its border with haiti
while haiti's interim prime minister
took charge
so what do we know about the gunman well
haiti's police chief says security
forces shot four of them dead and
arrested two others
and the haitian ambassador to the u.s
says they posed as u.s drug enforcement
agents to get into melisa's residence
it seems that this horrible act was
carried out
by well trained professionals killers
so let's step back for just a minute
this is haiti it shares an island in the
caribbean with the dominican republic
but it's a lot poorer and has a history
of political instability
moise's time in office was no different
[Music]
giovano moise made his money as a fruit
exporter before he became president in
2017.the promising to fix
haiti's problems at one point javanelle
moise offered a glimmer of hope for
haiti
at a time of numerous crises
[Music]
his presidency was contested from the
start and after a while
opposition parties and many haitians
began to accuse him of being autocratic
in late 2019 parliamentary elections
were postponed
and moise started to run haiti by
issuing decrees
he created a new intelligence agency
said he wanted to change the
constitution
and also said stuff like this
this year things got even more tense
a lot of people in haiti including many
of its top lawyers
said that based on the constitution
moise's presidential term ended in
february
but moise rejected that idea and said
that because his swearing-in ceremony
had been delayed
he was actually entitled to another year
so heidi was already going through a
political crisis when moise's
assassination
took it to another level whatever
happens next
one thing's for sure people in haiti
need things to change
the majority of haitians earn less than
two dollars a day
now factor in natural disasters
the country still hasn't recovered from
a devastating earthquake in 2010
and hurricane matthew in 2016.
today add in the pandemic plus things
like inflation and shortages of food and
fuel
then add crime the un says a two-week
surge in gang violence in june
forced more than 8 000 women and
children out of their homes
for weeks now violence in haiti's
capital has been
out of control gangs are now said to be
in charge of entire areas of
port-au-prince
the assassination of president moise has
now raised the possibility of
even more lawlessness haiti's acting
prime minister
claude joseph wants people to stay calm
while investigators look for answers
but answers to haiti's problems like so
much else in the country
have been really hard to come by
[Music]
you